what's happening there reject nation
greg
and ah john that's right get excited
because john's here
we are going to watch start today a
series i have wanted to start up seeing
clips of i
might have seen an episode or two years
ago i've been like
itching for a comedy show to start up on
youtube
so we're going with brooklyn nine nine i
feel like john's in the same boat as me
when it comes to brooklyn nine-nine one
they're like yeah we're going to start
this up
i know it's very different from all the
other shows that we usually cover
for youtube it'd be nice to have like a
weekly show or maybe twice a week
something that's just we know we
guaranteed laughs for us
yeah come out with us come to find out
this is the deepest most
thought-provoking we need to take notes
police damage the allegory show yeah
it's gonna be great
guys subscribe and click that
notification bell get notified when our
reaction for the next brooklyn nine-nine
episode is up if this all goes
well hit that like button full-length
watch will be over at our patreon page
where you sync up with the time code we
also cover a whole bunch of shows over
there with the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch along
included those thumbnails are just a few
of the shows that we cover
big thanks to pratham jindal for editing
these highlights for us anywho
let's watch this i'm so excited
[Music]
this job is eating me alive i can't
breathe anymore
not becoming like them
i am them i don't know hey what are you
doing weirdo i'm doing the best speech
from donnie brasco
what's up get it together man i already
solved the case
we're looking for three white males one
of whom has sleeve tats on both arms
and how do you know that i had an
informant on the inside
his code name fuzzy cuddle bear
he's an anacam you got lucky
no i got here five minutes before you
and figured that in this gigantic
electronic store there had to be at
least one working camera
you did it fuzzy you busted them it's
time to come home
i'm not sure if i can i've been
undercover so long
he's a cadbury bear he would be a fun
cop
absolutely yes i did crack the case so
santiago would you do the honors i hate
this oh yeah
and you're just gonna want to add one
i'm winning
i already want them to get together
not gonna happen man jp
updated hey terry crews earlier this
morning
someone decided to shoot and kill luxury
food importer henry morgenthau
morgenthau cleaning lady during her
interview i deduced using expert
detective work
that she had something super gross on
her chin
it was just old person gunk you know how
old people always have that gunk on them
oldie gunk could be
couldn't you think about the new captain
uh no and i don't care
i just wish captain mcginley never left
he was the best he was
terrible just liked him because he let
you do anything you wanted
on your marks get set go
what the hell's going on around here
fire extinguisher roller chair derby
[Laughter]
okay
oh have fun hey that captain was
triggering on friends
phil lord and chris miller yeah
i saw them in the eps but i know they
directed it
following every rule and the patrol
guide
meet morpzy robot captain engage
is that what you think hey new captain
alert
you must be the new ceo i'm detective
jack peralta great to meet you
the next time i see you i'd like you to
be wearing a necktie i'm your new
commanding officer
captain ray holt speech that was my
speech
short sweet
[Laughter]
does anyone get a little bit of a gay
vibe
sergeant you were in the 1-8 with me
though you were significantly
fatter sir they called me cherry titties
because i had titties yes i remember
though to be fair it was
accurate
[Laughter]
okay tell me about your detective squad
um well scully hitchcock and daniels
they're pretty much worthless but they
make good coffee
copy that all three of them make cookies
rosa diaz tough smart hard to read and
really scary
tell me who has me for secret santa oh
that takes all the fun out of it
it's scully he got you a scarf i'll make
him return it
yes you will
he's a gun tell me about peralta jacob
peralta is my best detective
he likes putting away bad guys and he
loves solving puzzles the only puzzle he
hasn't saw
is how to grow up that was very well put
you know how important this is to me
this precinct is doing fine but i want
to make it the best one in brooklyn i'm
so glad we're watching this
it's like it's already like friends i
don't want to stop hanging out with
great work detective you get a tie yeah
that's mine you took it from my desk
that's right charles good solve ty for
you thanks yeah
yeah he's a little too serious what do
you think rosa seems cool
he seems cool i agree
valued at what six thousand dollars six
thousand dollars for a ham
jamon iberico is an amazing cured ham
all right listen up everybody better
contact captain holt let him know we got
a ten tie situation
speaking of ties where's yours meet more
captain
hey welcome to the murder what are you
doing here
i'd like to know what my detectives are
up to that'll come by you take santiago
knock on doors
see if the neighbors heard anything hey
rosa rosa rosa
um i i just happen to notice
that uh there's an old movie festival
play at the film forum this week
you want to go sure cool
awesome there's a bunch of movie options
i'll probably just go
should you say yes like citizen kane
citizen kane is terrible
pick a good movie good call smart
i'll do it i'll pick a better movie than
citizen kane
have you seen this man before he was
shot last night
thank you no sir
[Laughter]
none of the neighbors heard or saw
anything while you're out you can buy
yourself a tie oh i'm wearing a tie
right now
check it out secret tie
first of all i think you're kind of
overdoing it with the manscaping does
anyone here know why it's so important
to me that you all dress appropriately
not one of you can solve this simple
mystery yeah what about this fancy ham
stuff pomona barico
yes is there a place nearby the crime
scene that sells it beneficio's might
let's go
you got to breathe the ceo first brief
him after we catch the guy
my name is ratco i don't know anything
oh
okay you recognize this guy henry
morgenthau
no maybe i don't know what happened
no more questions you do know morgan how
he came in here tried to sell you some
hams you knew they were worth a lot of
money so you tried to steal them from
him when he wasn't home only he was home
so you shot him
does that sound familiar
ma'am if you can just get down or ignore
me and continue shopping
i think i know where they shot this
how are you still here oh no no no
no no i cannot serve that ice cream
anymore
not brief you and yes he did get away
but i got you hazelnut
is he seriously assigning me to the
records room you're lucky man
i wish i could get a sign here full-time
you wrong about hoe that man has
forgotten more about being a cop than
you will ever know
in 1981 he caught the disco strangler
yes it's over disco man put down the
yo-yo and back away from the girl
so what movie did you get us tickets to
oh well just to be safe
i bought tickets to all of them oh no
no buddy what's up because you're
sort of opinionated you think i'm
opinionated
okay here's an opinion for you you're a
bad judge of character and your shirt
looks like vomit
so we can go see north by northwest
we're not seeing a movie together
[Music]
hey captain so you found something hey i
like the toy if you can't beat them join
them
anyway i think i got something good here
turns out the name ratco is made up
but i was digging through these files
one of which i literally found in a
spider web
it turns out there's a bunch of
references to a serbian thug street
names
the rat and the butcher it was known to
hang out at a storage unit near borum
park
which has red soil hence the muddy red
footprint on morganthous counter
that's fine work detective testament to
what can be achieved when you dress
appropriately let's pound it out
i do there had to be soccer
let's share it with the whole team
santiago boyle diaz get in here yes
bring everyone and a camera that's not
necessary
let's have a hand there's a fine master
detective jake peralta
yeah let's have a hand everyone get them
ahead yeah nice no record of bracco on
the ledger
must use cash well i for one am just
pumped to be on the stakeout with you
captain
does he always talk as much i just tuned
it out it's like a white noise machine
okay first of all that's racist
with all due respect sir why'd it take
you so long to get your first command
because i'm gay
[Laughter]
seriously i'm surprised you didn't know
i don't try to hide it
[Music]
damn i am not a good detective
here i feel bad that you spent all that
money on the movie tickets why don't you
just go to the movies with no
well this is awkward it's not awkward
i like your company you're sweet
the nypd was not ready for an openly gay
detective
but then the old guard died out suddenly
they couldn't wait to show off the fact
that they had a highly ranking gay
officer
i made captain but they put me in a
public affairs unit but all i ever
really wanted was my own command
and i'm not going to screw it up captain
i'm sorry i
i feel like a jackass but on the flip
side
there's racco humility over i'm amazing
[Music]
humility
oh man the book of quotes to use
shooter anything that moves
great to see you you can't stop me plus
if you take a look to your left you'll
see
detectives boyle and diaz right there is
detective santiago
and behind you is captain holt the point
is my team has you surrounded
oh my god i just got the tie thing
captain i just figured it out
maybe now's not the best it's a uniform
we're a team
[Music]
off the team for so long and now you're
the coach and you want us to all wear
that same uniform
boom nailed it yes you did now just
arrest radco
all right go down drop the weapon hands
on your head
no oh whoa nice stick
what's wrong with you never took off the
speedo big mistake
great work team
i smiled yeah smiled
yeah buddy ah it was great that was
awesome that was what i needed that was
a delight that was amazing
that made me feel so good inside it's
like solid
solid i'm tempted to like talk about
this for so long
but you know like we got so many
episodes gotta break down the easter
eggs and all the hidden roses
we have so many episodes to go through
and every tv show
especially network tv i'm constantly
reminded of all right you gotta give it
a few episodes you gotta give it like
a few like four to six on average and
for a
pilot damn that is solid
this is crisp this is like a crisp solid
pilot you get to know everyone in a very
fluid manner the dynamics the
relationships they all make perfect
sense um the motifs and tools they use
to introduce everyone i'm forgetting
everyone's names
but like you have the like with the
captain showing up and then terry crews
having to
name drop everyone i mean like right
from the very beginning you immediately
get andy samberg's character okay he's
like a goof-off detective
has this image of a slacker but then you
know he solves the case the very opening
scene you're like oh but he's actually
good at his job you know like oh that's
cool and then you get like the chemistry
banter between him and
do you know where that characters they
are or the girl's name was it not
blanking on her right now an attractive
funny woman whoever acted funny
uh yeah the the the detective uh he's
competing with
also you know i i don't know how every
episode will be shot
but i thought there was some cool like
subtle direction
that they chose with the camera angles
like phil lord and chris miller
i don't know if i would have paid
attention to it as much if i didn't know
phil lord and chris miller were
directing it
but because of that i did they did a lot
where they had the right blend
of mockumentary style but but it was
like halfway there so that way it didn't
feel like you were watching a
mockumentary it didn't feel too much
like the office
no no it could have like they they did
it hand held and there were certain
shots where it felt like
mockumentary-esque
especially when um man we need to learn
some character names hold on let me just
pull tonight
yeah okay amy santiago's her name all
right got it especially notice in the
shot when
charles asked rosa out camera was locked
off of the way it punched him but then
there was also these
other shots like in the grocery store
where it looked like it was from the
the pov of one of those like circle
mirror
cameras that you see in history
absolutely so there's some interesting
uh direction flourishes they had here
and then also some like cutaways that
you've
seen like a phil lord and chris miller
style i loved it i thought it was like
everyone has chemistry like
everyone has chemistry like it's a great
ensemble i love the flip what they do
with terry crews
yes of he's like the like the one who
looks like he should be the action hero
but he's the most scared of me in the
video but you know i was like psyched
out when andy sandberg's in the records
department like this is the place to be
yeah yeah and i mean he plays that role
really naturally and this did a really
nice job of just setting up
both the characters but then also some
of the dynamics we can expect moving
forward
like between boyle and rosa or like
between peralta and santiago perant
peralta and the chief
yeah and i'm like really excited to see
what that grows into because even though
yeah i mean like it's funny on the beat
humor it seems like it also has a good
grasp on
who the characters are and some of that
comes from the natural charisma of the
actors and the kinds of characters that
they play
well in but also you know you have to
take
time and care and i feel like that's
something phil lord and chris miller are
really good at with any project
they touch is making sure that it has
you know the whimsy
and the fun elements of like we're
poking fun at you know
the cop procedural genre so like you
know that cutaway
to him solving the disco murder is like
you know a perfect
nod or like classic cop shows but it
doesn't get too lost in the weeds of
doing that and i feel like also
looking at the visual style too it's
like certain shows especially
since the advent of the office do go i
feel like really
hard really lay it on thick and go like
see you know like this this
you know a fly in the wall kind of style
that people love and i feel like
all of the elements they really tempered
quite well so it's like yeah you can
have the fun of the police procedural
situation but also there were a couple
moments like i actually liked
the tie around with the whole theme with
the ties yeah yeah
they're putting it together and like the
way that that created an
actual character arc for their little
relationship with
like a learning lesson yeah and it
immediately
endears you both to the rascal who you
need to kind of bring down to a human
level but also the tight ass you know
chief who all
then you need to humanize a little bit
and and yeah just like the character
comedy
the jokes the writing like everything
was on point man i mean yeah uh
captain holt i i think it like it's such
a great dynamic between
again like that's that personality that
we love andy sandberg for
where he has like the guy who's like
very loose there is like a natural
slacker-esque
you know like a big classic cool chill
class
clown kind of kid that you you would
have i love how they do emphasize like
but he's really good at his job
you know like yeah i think that adds a
different edge to it and also with
detective uh captain holt he is like
technically this
like the the straight man i mean he's
gay but you know
even that's a joke yeah like the
receptionist lady brings it up
at the beginning yeah gay vibes it's
just like a joke
and you finally really i love the reveal
openly
or whatever yeah i don't know what was
really funny about that is
even though like his delivery is so much
based on like
not really smiling being as
straightforward
as possible captain whole character but
he's still
hilarious like it's he's funny he's
really still has a
great grasp of the comedy behind what
he's doing
he's not just there for other people to
be funny bouncing off of him like he's
also
really funny yeah he's got that subtle
expression where it's like he's deadpan
but he will throw in inflections that
are very full of personality yeah he's
got rhythm
yeah and it takes a lot of skill like
it's no wonder they have a veteran actor
like andre brower doing that because you
know that's not as easy to do as looks
no no no and plus i mean too you got
some really fun character actors popping
up like fred armisen like for just
one beat but he's so good at again
creating these
like weird awkward but hilarious little
characters and stuff like that and then
that makes me excited for you know like
andy sandberg from snl
so yeah yeah yeah it's like they gotta
they gotta know every comedian so
imagine the potential for you know
cameos and other fun characters to pop
up and whatever
yeah and i think the chemistry latino
andre brauer is his name
andre brauer be having like a veteran
actor i don't know where
what andy sandberg's celebrity status
was at the time that
was obviously post snl just as he was
leaving yeah
okay bigger pastures all right that
makes sense but but like the two of them
together were
so like better than i you i would ever
think so yeah this is a solid ass show
and it's a detective show too like
beyond all that it has all this heart
yes it's mainly sets out to be a comedy
and they're making they're poking fun at
tropes and it's
like a workplace type of comedy but it's
still like they're still doing detective
stuff
yeah i'm like oh that's cool it's like a
thrilling mystery yeah
i got a pulse i love this this is a
fantastic
fantastic first episode rare is the day
you get a pilot that's
that good yeah i mean most pilots
nowadays are designed for binge watch
shows
yeah you gotta like just mention but
here for a weekly show i'm like damn i
would tune in next week
this was written as though it had to
hook people to come back to watch their
tv next week i loved it everyone is so
funny in this
guys brooklyn nine-nine are you guys
fans i don't know if this is one of
those shows that evolves into
you know uh stronger character stories
where it's like oh i gotta avoid
spoilers
it's very abstract by season four
it's like ethereal and dreamlike yeah
it's like a noah holly show at that
point you won't understand it but it's
hilarious
you know what i mean i don't want to i
probably won't detain
the comments and stuff here but leave
your thoughts down below anyway
engagement helps out the video's
performance hit that like button
subscribe check us on patreon and last
but not least
maria hammond if there's anyone who can
help bring joy into our lives
you know since this being a comedy
episode who's brought a lot of smiles to
us this week
it's you did an unboxing video over our
patreon where maria sent
john a thousand gifts she's all the
gifts
but she said uh olivia and i
oh is it in here no it's it's in the
other room damn uh she said olivia and i
this here's just a photo of the
thumbnail two of those are not from
maria
but most of those are from maria she
sent us so much stuff
you're constantly checking up on us you
know every once in a while she sends me
a message on twitter making sure i'm
just doing okay
your motherly qualities really shine
through and looking out for our
well-being so
thank you for all you gift us with but
mainly thank you for gifting us
with your care and your presence we love
you
thank you for being you maria hope you
have a great month
but i hope next month sucks for you yeah
this month yeah you learned it this
month
but next month unless you send us more
stuff and then you deserve
to have a good money how you earn
transactional
good months i hope it's good for you in
total
and for the rest perpetuity but 2022
yeah look out